Trauma occurs in many forms
ranging from verbal to physical and our sexual
Whether you've personally experienced abuse or have witnessed it
We want you to know that it's not your fault nor are you alone
Not only is it hard to talk about
But it follows you even after it's over
We hope wherever you are today that you're in a safer place
Our hearts go out to anyone who's been a victim of childhood abuse
In our description box below
We've included a few hotlines in case you need to contact someone for help
As always You can also reach out in the comment box
Here are 7 ways childhood trauma follows you into adulthood
1. you can't seem to remember much of your younger years at all
Do your high school years feel like a blur?
You might find yourself drawing a blank when someone brings up a childhood memory
And you can't recall the same one
People with childhood trauma may experience
"Flashbulb" memories
In which they remember vivid moments, but not the full event
When you look back on the past
It's made up of more black holes than fully written chapters
You might even feel like someone or something has stolen your childhood
Depending on the severity of the events
2. You find yourself in toxic relationships
If you've ever watched or read the
"Perks of Being a Wallflower"
You'd be familiar with the quote
"We accept the love. We think we deserve"
When you grow up in a household devoid of love and emotional support
Healthy relationships are a foreign concept to you
In fact
Many people who face childhood trauma often adopt the fearful avoidant attachment style
Where they want emotionally close relationships
But find it hard to trust or depend on others completely
Consequently without knowing it you might seek destructive relationships
Mistaking the mistreatment and uncertainty for excitement
3. Or you feel like you don't deserve love at all
People who experienced abuse in their childhoods
Might avoid romantic relationships altogether
Believing they can't be loved by others
This is known as the anxious preoccupied attachment
Where the individual wants to establish emotional intimacy with others
But often fears rejection
As a result
Vulnerability is usually avoided
When they've only been hurt by people they once trusted
This kind of trauma doesn't just ache
It ruins you
4. You develop Passive-agressiveness
Did you grow up in a household with anger all the time?
It can be so scarring that you might even grow fearful of this emotion
You learned at a young age that none of your emotional needs were important
So you've only resorted to burying or suppressing them
As you reach adulthood
You'll continue to exercise passive aggressive behavior
Because straightforward communication was avoided when you were a child
5. Negative self-talk is amplified
Childhood trauma gets into victims heads
And makes them believe they won't ever be good enough
It's not something they can just snap out of or fix with positivity
It's scary
And real how convincing their parents might have been
When their words and actions cut them deep
6. You ride an emotional roller coaster
You might either feel too much or not enough at
All trauma can cause a disruption in your emotional well-being
Signs include trouble making decisions
Impulsive behavior
And random outbursts of anger or frustration
7. You don't know who you are
Identity is difficult
But it seems more impossible to grasp or pin down when you face childhood trauma
It's slippery like a fish
And the more you try to see yourself
The less you begin to recognize who you thought you were
Have you or anyone, you know experienced any of these symptoms
Please share your thoughts with us below
We're an open-minded team and we will never judge you for your stories
In fact, we often find them inspiring
Also, don't forget to subscribe to our channel
For more helpful tips and share this video with others
Thanks so much for watching
You